Masculine masculinity is tyranny,
but the right amount is order and too much femininity is chaos,
which is the word for the right amount of femininity.
That's a really good question.
I read that a bit earlier and I couldn't come up with something immediate,
but the only thing I can think of is that often femininity has been
characterized as wisdom and maybe that's so,
so the,
the wisdom that God in the Judeo Christian tradition that God consults is
feminine.
That's an old tradition and maybe that's because order needs to be leaving with
the right amount of chaos in order for wisdom to emerge the order,
it can be blinded,
tyrannical and dead.
And so it's,
it's the mixture of the right amount of chaos that turns that order into wisdom
and then that wisdom is often personified as feminine.
Now that doesn't exactly answer your question because it doesn't make the right
balance.
You still don't have tyranny order,
you still don't have order,
tyranny,
chaos.
You're still missing the proper word there.
Um,
I don't,
it's,
it's a good question.
And,
and the wisdom ideas the best I can make of it for now.
Is it better to marry someone with your temperament or a contrasting
complimentary temperament?
Well,
there is evidence on this and basically you don't want to marry someone with
whom you're two mismatched.
Now the only possible exception to that is neuroticism.
You know,
neuroticism is a good predictor of marital trouble and it's a good predictor of
trouble period or perhaps sensitivity to trouble,
which is in some sense the same thing.
It's very,
and I don't know of any research specifically pertaining to this.
Um,
now I know that people who are high in neuroticism are more likely to miss work
and to visit the doctor and to,
um,
and,
and to be unhappy in their marriages and so forth.
And that may also account for why 75% of divorces are initiated by women.
Um,
and I think women are more sensitive to negative emotion,
partly because they have to take care of infants and need to be more sensitive
to threat.
And perhaps because sexuality is more dangerous to women and perhaps because
women are physically smaller.
And all of this seems to kick in at puberty anyways.
It isn't obvious to me that you want to match someone with regards to
neuroticism.
If you're high in neuroticism,
I think if you're high in neuroticism,
you need to find someone who is low in neuroticism,
um,
because then you have someone around to calm you down.
Now apart from that,
the research literature does indicate that match is better and you can see why
it's hard for extroverts and introverts to get along if they're,
especially if they're extreme extroverts and extreme introverts because an
extreme extrovert always wants to be with other people and in groups and an
extreme introvert hardly ever wants that.
And that's a very,
very difficult thing to negotiate.
And then with conscientiousness,
same thing.
If you're really high in orderliness,
it's very hard to be married to someone who is very low and ordered.
You're going to end up doing all the cleaning,
for example,
that will drive you crazy.
And if you're high and industriousness,
same thing,
healthy,
are super high and industriousness and orderliness,
you might want someone who's maybe moderate in both to kind of temper you a bit
because one of the problems with being too high in conscientiousness is that you
can't stop working and you should probably stop working from time to time.
Agreeableness,
same thing.
Hard for an agreeable and disagreeable person to get along.
You know,
the agreeable person will always be
the disagreeable person.
Yeah.
Who won't shy away from conflict is likely to dominate the agreeable person
quite badly.
So that's a tough bridge to two.
That's a tough chasm to bridge as well.
So you look for temperamental similarity.
I'm at now it's complicated because like if you're really,
really low and industriousness and you marry someone else who's really low and
industriousness,
well that's going to be trouble for both of you because there isn't going to be
anyone around who's going to do the work.
So,
um,
you might understand each other better,
but as a long term strategy it's not a very good one.
So
it seems like your message is primarily positive masculine,
whereas the positive feminine is not elaborated with near the same resolution.
What do you think?
Um,
I don't really think that's true.
I,
I think that might be somewhat true of 12 rules for life,
although I'm not convinced of that.
That message and 12 rules for life is to find a balance between order and chaos.
And there's plenty of discussion in there about the danger of an excess of both.
Certainly maps of meaning is,
um,
elaborated out more with regards to the positive masculine.
Alright.
With regards to maps of meaning is elaborated out more completely than 12 rules
with regards to the positive role of the masculine and the feminine.
Um,
I think it's complicated in part because the feminine classically speaking is
associated with smaller scale,
intimate familial groupings.
And so
in a world that's obsessed with adaptation to large scale social systems,
it's harder to make a case for the role of the feminine.
We don't really understand role of the feminine in large scale social
structures.
So,
and you know,
we don't have a cultural myth apart from beauty and the beast.
Let's say the describes the role of an independent female operating in the
fundamentally masculine social world.
And we don't even know what something like that would look like.
And there aren't guiding stories to some degree because women haven't been able
to do that except in the last hundred years.
So I don't know what,
what the positive feminine on a large scale would look like.
And we don't have guiding stories for that.
This is partly to underlined the absolutely radical nature of the birth control
pill.
And,
and not only that,
but the provision of,
of,
of technological devices that aid women in dealing practically with their weekly
or their monthly menstrual cycle,
which was also a huge impediment to women in terms of interacting in the,
let's say,
the patriarchal world.
So now women can take their place in the broader cultural world and we don't
know what the model for that is.
So,
you know,
you might say,
well,
they should adopt the heroin masculine perspective.
And certainly to some degree that's true,
but that's not a particularly fruitful archetype when it comes to having a
family and having a family is actually extraordinarily important.
And it's certainly the thing that dominates the thoughts of the majority of
women as they approached their thirties all cultural noise to the contrary.
So it's something we're still puzzling out.
And I suppose I'm still puzzling it out too.
I mean,
with my daughter,
I tried to encourage her to be as sharp and is intelligent and critically minded
and ambitious as she could be,
but also let her to let her know that if she,
and she,
she,
she was always interested in having kids.
Um,
but to also let her know that having a family who is an extremely important
thing,
um,
how to balance that.
Well that is the modern conundrum isn't it?
We want to figure out how to maximize our access to the talents of women,
but also to set up a situation where it's possible for talented women and women
of all talents,
let's say as well,
but talented women who have options in the workplace to also have a family.
And this is a tremendously complex problem and it isn't clear how it's going to
be solved.
You know,
there is data showing,
you know,
you say,
well,
men should pick up more of the feminine role.
And I suppose that's possible.
But there is good data showing,
for example,
that if he show women pictures of men engaged in classically masculine
endeavors,
you know,
fixing a roof or fixing the plumbing or so forth,
um,
or in feminine endeavors doing the dishes and,
and,
and vacuuming that the women rate the man who are doing the female tasks as well
as less sexually attractive.
And so it's not all on the men with regards to the utility of them picking up a
more feminine role,
you know,
and it isn't necessarily the case that women will find men who are more
domestic,
also maximally sexually attractive.
Those things don't necessarily go together.
So this is very,
very complicated.